all right cool
all right so we we done with this area
yeah i got my loot i think now he said
during the fight i could switch weapons
with the d-pad
yeah but i can't do it now because we're
not actually in combat right
oh i got perception oh animals here
if i ever catch who did this hair
dad was that major prasad
well that's that battle chick would that
be safe
yeah [ __ ] it
and achieve it again
awesome general vargas
wade wilson i feel like the series x
should be loading this quick
yeah that's what i don't feel the nvme
tower
when there were 50 cold logic
says i should turn you away
that there aren't enough of you left to
do the job at hand
patriot but that dorsi ambush was
my fault and
i owe you more than explanation
yeah you do but they try to jump us so
here's something more tense oh
the doors he got somebody
they attacked my city yo they are
violent trying to burn down our jail
if you want some vengeance for what was
done to you
he's yours where's the option for that
kill does kill the dudes and then what
you do here's your leadership
if i had leadership too i could do he's
your prisoners you gotta that we gonna
murk him because i ain't like how them
dudes did us
be my guest
yeah yeah yeah that's right on
and maybe before all this is over
i will but for now let me address your
immediate needs
in addition to this base and the eight i
promised your general
i'll be giving you the resources to
return your force to full strength
recruiting training and equipping
it's not enough i know
the men and women you lost can never be
replaced but it's what i can give you
i hope you appreciate that we appreciate
it
we'll see all right oh there's more it's
mad choices
okay so no deal campus was your fault
did you owe us
give us our supplies and let us get i
might rock with that
better than that i say we do all we want
to do is complete our vengeance on the
dorsis
we want to do that
oh i say always up but we won't say you
want to do that
yeah but i'm saying like the ambush was
his fault though
yeah but it's not like he ain't trying
to take ownership of that he's like it's
my fault like
i'm willing to help you though yeah he
gave us the body that's true that's true
yeah yeah
vengeance is fine honorable even
just don't forget that your primary
reason for being here is to save my
nation
that's how arizona gets what it needs
now imagine if this game didn't have
this
voice my name is saul buchanan that's
what i'm saying would be
this game sounds just like that
yes joe pardon acknowledgement patriarch
daisy an update on the garden of the
gods
all right the garden of the gods
two of my best are waiting for you
inside darius kwan of the marshalls
and my various pawns sound like a
brother i'm gonna have to see what's
going on
i'll be in when i'm done here ones if
he's white
glad to see some friendly faces been
rough around here these last few days
dorsey's attacked us too snuck inside
colorado springs and killed a lot of
people
situations under control mostly
i own this conversation oh okay
i can still move it even though i own it
even though you can
see what they are
the patriarch thank god they never got
near him
he's the only thing keeping colorado
from tearing itself apart
and sorry about these alarms something
does feel like trouble is there's a
bunch of angry robots guarding the
computer that shuts them off
how you deal with them is your call your
base
your rules
[Music]
yeah i see it that's where i just
clicked it saying that we should pick
that
but what if i pick okay okay but it says
i only become
so yeah you click what
they got to be the source of what's
going on so we're going to fight right
into them eventually
a few days back but
[Music]
ah let's talk after you kill the alarms
i can hardly hear myself think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but when you press the power button it
flickers to life the computer beeps
security system flashes across the
display every attempt
to access the menu is met with command
access access
only
install us command
terrible photos of your face slowly
appear on the screen
[Music]
all right
[Music]
well done rangers good to see the place
up and running where was this dude and
these people at
that's what i'm saying where was they at
when we were beefing with
blackens the buchanan name with every
breath he takes
consequently i banished him they've been
skulking in the shadows ever since
but lately there's been rumors that i'm
on my last legs
lies of course but apparently my dear
children believe
them and they've started making new
plans
you need to round us up you want to ask
that machine
let's go with the beef what else you
need us to round them up yeah let's do
that
let's go with the beef
ain't you smart i'm not worried about my
children defeating me rangers they won't
not even liberty what worries me is the
destruction they'll reek as they fail
they'll tear my land and my people to
shreds they'll burn everything i've
accomplished to act
that's why they have to be stopped
before they can start
that's why you rangers have to find them
and bring them home to me
as and when i say bring them home i mean
bring them
home alive they're my blood
kill them and we'll have a problem
do i make myself stay violent
man what if dear what if it's impossible
what if this is
sure let's go you've already done the
impossible by making oh my god
i trust you find a way to
make it possible no ain't no promises
bro
let me tell you where their children
start while they shooting i'm shooting
back
victories hold up in aspen valours
under the protection of the gippers in
denver and
liberty is raising an army against me
somewhere out on the eastern plains
liberty isn't it you need to know let me
tell you right now
i'm just crazy for one thing oh you
might have plenty of
people why ask us today with your child
yeah why are they gonna deal with
children
like why don't you you got them dudes
back there what they doing
loyalty that's why i trust my guards but
they don't leave my side
ever oh so these are the only people
he's got everybody else that's what it
is
everybody else is making plans for when
i'm gone
the hundred families the gippers the
marshals
they're all out for themselves and they
know my kids would make good figureheads
give them some legitimate what kind of
name is that colorado nice and
to bring vic val and libby back home
might think they'll get a better deal
elsewhere
but not you i'm the only one who can
save your people
nobody else can get supplies to arizona
before they starve to death
that's why it's you who's doing this
you've got the only loyalty that works
the loyalty of self-interest
let's talk about this liberty
liberty's got more brains and cunning
than both her brothers put together
she's the only one who could actually
run colorado
problem is she'd run it as a goddamn
slave state everyone in chains
everyone working for her wouldn't worry
about her for now though
best to wait until you got a little more
firepower you're gonna be well protected
basically we ain't ready oh we're not
don't give her a compliment
at least i raised one
oh thanks for the answer yeah the other
two
anything else
of course now if you want a chance to
impress me
and maybe get a little payback that call
i got outside was from sheriff daisy
the head of the marshals in colorado
springs she's having trouble rousting
some dorsis who've been holed up in the
garden of the gods since their parade
fell apart
why don't you go give her a hand sounds
like show us what this is
rangers
sounds like a piece of cake something oh
my
gosh yeah i should have picked that up
ourselves rangers just don't get
killed i want to return on my investment
all right
let's move out you leveled up
yeah gotta see what's going on
these people seem pretty stacked though
all right so let's let's talk right now
what do you plan on doing in terms of
skills
foreign
what are you working on so you know
skill wise
um i think i'm going to work on
general skills i'm going to work on
weird science
i was going to say no for before you do
actually be something to say
oh no i'm talking about skills
ah okay that's what okay so you work i'm
yeah i'm gonna do
because we want to make sure we don't do
the same one same thing yeah
i say you do i'll do lock picking and
you do uh nerd stuff for survival or
something like that
i don't know toaster i need to like
combat skills i haven't really put much
of my combat skills
oh yeah but i need to put the majority
of mine on combat skills
yeah it makes you more effective with
swimming machine gun
yeah my combat is trash i don't have
anything
i'm gonna put all mine in lock picking
right now
that way we have something in lock
picking
you get your your combat skills up keep
in mind we're about to get two uh we're
about to get more people too
so stinky
ain't gonna shock us how often you come
across sniper rifles in this game
we have a bunch right now but i wouldn't
worry about that build that character
around what you've already built
what about melee combat is that even
stuff in here we'll get characters that
can do that better than the character
you built
because we'll each get two characters
okay
three characters all explosives
come talk to me when you've got them
i'm gonna mess with leadership
please don't shoot
let's get your clothes ready she's
surrounded by a group of
shoes who are you
you're not dressed like the marshalls
nation gives you more action i speak for
these people
we've been living here for months and
we've got the other soldiers
around i know a few of us might be able
to earn our keep we're
not trained fighters but we can defend
ourselves with a knife or a club
you said yes
we won't be any trouble oh and uh one of
our people is missing
everyone we gotta make ourselves useful
around here
what is one internal oh asparagus
nvme what it is
fire
look i can run a rocket i think i had a
shirt like that once
a long time ago arizona
ari zone ah that sounds
far real far i'll just be
thank god thank you so much man i
owe you
[Music]
where did you go on a map i'm just
looking around the map
the place where you are
[Music]
oh there's armor in here
oh
need to fill you in on a few things
rangers
good job rangers nice to be able to hear
yourself
i think again and now that it's quite
high again rangers i don't know where
you
are i'm sorry about your people but now
that you're here
we'll do what we can to get you back on
your feet and they already got you one
of the best
yeah howdy rangers
uh while you were dealing with the
alarms i took the liberty box
should be more recruits arriving you
leave the area ready to tell me how you
want to fill out your squad
absolutely we can talk about recruitment
anytime
now you're the boss here so i'm not
going to tell you what
that'll give you a chance to see if any
of the junk around here
anyway your call colorado springs is
straight out the main gate
if you want to go to denver or aspen
just hop back in your car
uh one sec forgive me for saying so but
i'm guessing you folks are gonna need as
much help in the field as you will here
in hq
so what if i joined your squad
at least until you find your feet great
[Music]
they really need to have a wish
here come over here we're going to take
out these things in here
pretty grand in here maybe you can make
it your trophy haul a museum or
something or a handball park
real
hey
that's crazy
he got all this good spots all right
don't come
oh you're controlling people
scroll the watch
kill the enemy with fire damage oh
we're gonna go get you went forward
right now
yeah i'm just right well there's here
computer
nerve stuff oh
[Music]
dude
that's a masterpiece
[Music]
are you healing
he's going to be continually just using
help okay and eventually
all right